last time we
started talking about the most General
type of
fmcw radar which is the mimo radar right
that's the case where you have multiple
transmitter antennas multiple receiver
antennas and then it enables you to this
this antenna diversity basically enables
you to determine the the direction of
arrival of targets with some clever DSP
so we started by introducing this idea
of the virtual antenna array and this is
a purely mathematical construction
basically if you have a mimo array which
has N Sub TX transmit antennas and N Sub
RX receive antennas so physically you
only have ntx plus nrx antenna elements
right
but mathematically we showed that it is
equivalent and by mathematically
equivalent I mean essentially the signal
that you receive from it is equivalent
to a a similar array single input
multi-output where you have just one
transmitter and you have P receivers
where p is equal to the number of
transmitters times the number of
receivers in the original antenna array
uh and then the way this uh virtual
antenna is constructed uh well it's
important to know where these virtual
elements are placed what are the the
locations of them the transmitter you
can assume it's at the origin it's at
zero uh and then the the positions of
the p uh receive antennas each of them
is the sum of the positions of one of
the original transmitters plus one of
the original receivers so the indexing
is K for original transmitter antennas Q
for original receive antennas and then P
for the virtual uh receive antennas and
then that's the tilde also is so that we
know when we talk about uh sorry the
prime the RTD Prime that's the position
of of the uh actually is my notation
inconsistent with the notes I think I
should remove the tildes here right to
be consistent with the lecture notes
maybe something like this so the tilde
is for the virtual array yeah you can
you can cross check uh but the point is
uh now we can uh basically do all of our
DSP uh in in the individual uh um in
this in the signal model that we Define
on the visual array so the way it looks
like is like let's say physically you
have a two by three mimo array so
there's the two triangles show the two
transmitters and the three diagonal
circles are the positions of the three
receivers so if you look say on your uh
PCB these are the positions that you see
so physically you have only five
antennas two plus three uh but the
virtual array would have six antennas uh
six receive antennas which are shown by
the squares here and then there's
there's two diagonal rows how did I get
this again from here you just add the
positions of the transmitters and the
receivers and then you kind of get that
that get that shape for the for the
virtual array and then we showed that
for the virtual array basically the full
signal model that we can work with uh
for the for the entire you know
end-to-end DSP pipeline is is given by
this so the if signal so the signal
after down conversion that you receive
from virtual antenna receiver number
Index P is equal to this summation I
from 1 to K this is uh to account for
receiving Echoes from multiple targets
right so say there's there's Big K
targets all simultaneously echoing back
so if you're summing the signals
received from all of them that's just a
superposition principle so that's why
there's this there's a sum here and then
the signal from each Target it has what
we call a spatial phase term which is
this e to the J big Omega p i p for the
index again for the virtual antenna I
for the Target that's why there's double
indexing here and this term uh I call it
the the spatial phase because there's
there's no temporal aspect to it right
it's just affected by the direction of
arrival of the of the echoes and then
there's the temporal part which is the
sifi of T and this one as you see it has
time dependence but it doesn't does it
does not have P dependence so it doesn't
matter which virtual antenna you look at
they all the waveform they receive that
the temporal part of it or the time
dependency of it is the same
the part that is different between
different receive antennas is this is
spatial report and that's why we focus
on this term when it comes to direction
of arrival estimation it's specifically
this special phase term Omega Pi is
given by this formula which is uh
basically or wave number minus or minus
wave number two pi over Lambda times the
norm of the position of the uh of the
virtual element of ritual antenna P
times sine of theta I where essentially
what we want at the end of the day is
this Theta I because that's the
direction of arrival of the uh of the
target so if you look at this if you
want to develop
DSP algorithms that estimate basically
Theta I for you for DOA it's uh it's
important to know basically your
algorithm needs to know what this term
is what the norm of
um uh the position of the antenna
elements are right so the geometry
basically matters and geometry by
geometry I mean these positions so here
in this case like the fact that they're
positioned diagonally that also affects
the phases that you receive in addition
to the Theta I so from this you can see
that like by changing the positions of
the of the elements it can affect the
performance of your DOA basically and
and we'll see that exactly how it
affects it today but
basically algorithms we went with the
simplest geometry that you can think of
which is a uniform linear array
basically this this here for instance is
not a uniform linear array uniform
linear array all your virtual elements
are are unaligned and they are equally
spaced so if I were to like draw a Ula
basically all elements are like this and
the spacing we call that d
so every every two Aerospace stay apart
and they are on the line and that's a
Ula
so again it's it's the simplest simplest
array geometry you can think of and and
then we developed the DSP for that and
we showed that to find a Theta I for Ula
uh you basically can just do another
Fourier transform from the signal model
we simplified it and we showed it like
another Fourier transform basically you
can recover this this data I okay so uh
here is uh on the slide
the end-to-end DSP for a mimo
um fmcw radar okay let's trace it again
together so this is essentially
everything we talked about not just DOA
range estimation velocity estimation
Target detection and DOA all the way to
so from raw signals that you receive
from the ADC ADC samples to the final
image which is say a point Cloud a 2d or
a 3D Point Cloud so you start with these
excuse me these if signals sif1 to sifp
so these are coming from the virtual
elements or the other way you can think
about it is each of these sifs is coming
from a combination of a transmit antenna
and a receive antenna right so transmit
number one transmitted receiver number
one receive trans with non-one
transmitted receiver number two receipts
so so all those combinations you put
them or you collect them together and
that's one what we call a raw data frame
okay so you have three indices you have
your virtual antenna index that's p uh
you have of course your ADC sample index
that we call n and we we know we use
multiple chirps in a frame so you have
your chip index inside the frame and
that's M okay so
um the basically the the
data format that that we work with it's
a it's a cube so you can populate them
in an M by n by P raw data Cube and then
you can start basically processing it
the way the processing is done typically
you first you range and Doppler
processing so you you can think of them
as two uh uh basically individual ffts
or you can combine them as a as a single
two-dimensional fft here we have shown
them as as independent ffts again
mathematically it's it's equivalent you
can decide how you like to do it but you
do it and point fft along the basically
ADC sample index or the Axis or the
n-axis so that's your your range
basically are along the rows here that's
your range ffd endpoint and then you do
your Doppler processing that's an
endpoint fft along the columns
right and again you have to do it for
every slice right like he again I'm I'm
not I'm just showing these for the First
Slice but after you you're done with
that you go through your second slice
you know or second virtual antenna and
do the same so for that you do you do a
Crossroads and that gives you your range
processing and you go across the columns
of it uh to do your Doppler processing
so you should go through the entire Cube
all the all the slices
so after that you're basically done with
range and Doppler processing you can do
Target detection
um with like fixed thresholding or a 2d
C4 so that what does that does for you
it basically chooses uh range and
Doppler indices that we think contains
an actual Target and everything else you
can you can assume there's nothing there
it's it's it's just it's just noise so
that's what we call L hat I and K hat I
so those are actual targets and then for
those L hat I and K hat I so if I clean
this a little bit so let's say
um just just pick
let's pick just one of those
combinations so let's say this cell here
is is one of those that that contains a
Target so of course after processing
right so this is one of those L hat I
K hat I indices and then you go for your
DOA processing you basically go go
through the third dimension so you go
basically in across all virtual antenna
elements so that becomes a vector of
length P that then you do an fft on and
then that fft essentially converts the
virtual antenna index to a DOA index
queue that we can then map to actual
angles with a simple you know
transformation that that we talked about
so that's your DOA processing there's a
the third fft essentially and then on
that you want to also detect after you
do that fft the third fft you look at
its amplitude and then you pick the
indices that are basically above a
threshold it could be a C4 threshold or
a fixed threshold that gives you
basically the Q Hat eyes which are
indices for the the doas of of where you
think the actual targets are and finally
so so at this point you have basically
three indices one for for Doppler
um
one for range
and one for DOA
so these are indices and then you can
map them to physical quantities which is
velocity in meters per second range in
meters and DOA in degrees or irradians
and and that conversion it's just you
know basically kind of like linear
Transformations except for DOA which
involves a arc sine transform as we saw
and by this point basically this is the
end of your DSP so you have detected
your targets and for each Target you
know the range you know the velocity you
know the angle and then you can decide
how you want to essentially visualize or
represent this uh you know fully
processed data a common way is to
generate a a point Cloud so a point
Cloud you basically use the range and
the angles of the targets and put a
point for every uh every Target in a in
the 3D space and generate a 3D Point
cloud or a 2d Point Cloud if you only
have say Azimuth angle then you may kind
of like a bird's eye view 2D point Cloud
sometimes I've seen that
velocity is also used in the in the
visualization a very interesting common
way is use velocity to assign colors to
the points in the point cloud like
things that are moving you can show them
in a different color it just makes it
more interesting richer representation
um
okay any questions about this the DSP of
fmcw Mima okay and one thing to note is
um
again there is there's different
variations of it this is this is you
know most of this is kind of like
standard vanilla DSP but but you would
see different variations of it like
another common one is um you can you can
it can you can see in the literature
that sometimes this this target
detection is that the 2D C4 is emitted
okay and you basically feed everything
into your DOA processing that's fine
still works and and then after that
instead of a one DC4 you do like a 3D C4
across range Doppler and DOA and you
know in one shot detect where the where
the targets are and then if you do that
you can basically combine range
processing Doppler processing and DOA
processing into one 3D fft
okay the point is it wouldn't be very
efficient because uh you would do a lot
of you know ffts where there is no
target so the reason I I like this
better is that you kind of make it more
efficient by filtering out a lot of the
data at this step with a 2d C4 and then
for DOA only basically focus on where
you think the targets are but again the
point is
off it
also as usual very important to always
remember the assumptions that went into
every step of the of the DSP so
specifically for instance for the DOA we
made a bunch of assumptions like the
fact that you can do a fft
it's correct only if you have a uniform
linear array if you if you array is a
different different type of an array
then this this algorithm wouldn't work
for it and you have to you know rethink
or find another algorithm that that
works
um okay questions
all right so one thing we haven't looked
at is from our DOA algorithm on this fft
algorithm uh What uh resolution we can
expect and what is the maximum field of
view that we get so those are the two
things uh exactly like uh the thing we
did for range and velocity processing
that after we developed the algorithm we
looked at the resolution and the maximum
range and velocity that we can get we're
going to do the same for this digital
beam forming algorithm that we developed
using ffts so the way is let's look at
resolution first
so uh let's look at basically two
adjacent DOA angles that our algorithm
can discriminate call them Theta q and
Theta Q Plus one so those correspond to
two adjacent ffd bins basically that's
kind of like the minimum angle you can
discriminate with an fft so let's take
the average of the two so Theta Q Plus
Theta Q Plus 1 over 2 that's the average
of the the the angles corresponding to
those two fft bins call that Theta and
that's kind of like our angle of
Interest so we want to see at that angle
what is the resolution to expect and
then the actual DOA resolution would be
the the difference between Theta q and
Theta Q Plus One all right so that's
just the Delta as you shift one fft bin
how much the angle changes so we want to
find this Delta Theta that's our DOA
resolution
so we know that there is a non-linear
mapping between the actual angle and the
fft frequencies so if you remember we
defined this parameter F sub Theta which
was equal to one over Lambda sine
Theta or make it more concrete so F
Theta I was 1 over Lambda sine Theta I
right so so and from the fft we actually
find these frequencies and then we apply
the inverse transform to find the angles
from the frequencies right so there was
this sine inverse transformation so
using that
the sine of theta Q minus sine of theta
Q Plus 1 that would be equal to Lambda
times Delta F Theta so Delta F Theta is
actually the width of one FSD bin which
as you know is equal to the sampling
rate F double Prime s divided by the
total number of points in the sft
divided by P okay and it's just a scaled
by Lambda and the sampling rate if you
remember for a Ula uniform linear array
was just equal to F double Prime s was
just one over D where D is the spacing
between the antenna elements right so
every two adjacent antennas where
basically a distance D apart so then
sine Theta Q minus sine Theta Q Plus 1
becomes equal to Lambda divided by P
times d what is big p total number of
virtual elements in the array D is the
spacing between them okay so
um but but we want to find Delta Theta
we just uh apply a little you know
geometric uh sorry trigonometric
identity if remember have this identity
which is sine Alpha minus sine beta
equals this which is 2 times the cosine
of alpha plus beta over 2 times sine of
alpha minus beta over 2. apply this to
this expression up here and the left
hand side becomes equal to 2 cosine
Theta times sine of Delta Theta over two
okay
and that the left hand side we haven't
touched it's Lambda over PD so at this
point we are pretty much done we just
make the assumption that Delta Theta
is a small right it's the resolution of
our of our radar and if it's if it's a
good resolution that angle is a small so
for a small Delta Theta you can
approximate sine of Delta Theta over 2
by just the angle itself in radians
right Delta Theta over 2. so I use that
so so plug that in here and then we can
solve for Delta Theta which is the
resolution we want to find it just
becomes equal to Lambda over P times D
times cosine Theta okay so this is that
this Delta Theta this is the DOA
resolution that we can get from our fft
algorithm again 4A uniform uniform
linear array very important this is not
true for any any arbitrary array but
this is very insightful I mean we did a
bunch of math but it's always you know
what's behind the math that is
interesting and insightful and important
which is if you look at this so we want
Delta Theta to be small right we want
good resolution meaning small Delta
Theta okay but here's
first observation that is very
interesting Delta Theta has this cosine
Theta term in the denominator which
means that the DOA resolution is not
uniform across the field of view of your
radar right if you look down bore side
that's where Theta is zero cosine Theta
would be one so you get best resolution
there but as you go to larger angles on
either side so as you go towards the
edges of the field of view of your radar
this cosine Theta term drops right large
Theta cosine Theta becomes a small which
means Delta Theta becomes large so you
have worse resolution towards the edges
of your field of view and better
resolution in the middle down board side
very important okay so it's it's it's
non-uniform DOA resolution
that's Insight number one number two is
what can we do design wise to improve
the resolution of our radar uh well
Lambda is Lambda it's kind of you know
it is what it is I mean of course
smaller Lambda which means higher
frequencies helps we know that's always
the case higher frequency is better
resolution and that's true in Optics
that's true in millimeter wave radar
that's through in uh Acoustics right uh
sonar and so on that's one of those you
know General Physics you know principles
that higher resolution higher frequency
better resolution so that's one but for
the case of radar you don't have much of
a choice like if you're working at 77
gigahertz that's you know there's a
little bit that you can you can vary
Lambda but you would have a lot of
flexibility in choosing p and d right p
is the total number of antennas and D is
the spacing between them so P times D is
what we call your total aperture size
right I mean technically P minus 1 times
D but let's call it P is large enough so
that's your aperture size and what I
mean by aperture size
is again if you look at your virtual
antenna array you have element one
element two all the way to the last one
so that's like RX1 to RX number P
and the total aperture size is basically
the entire span like that distance that
your end to end your first element and
your last element how far apart they are
that's basically how big your full
aperture antenna aperture is and bigger
aperture better resolution again exact
same thing as we saw in sonar for
instance in sonar when we were talking
about transducers if you remember we
said bigger bigger transducer you know
aperture size means more focused more
more narrow beams better better DOA
resolution same for radar this is also
true in Optics I mean for instance in
photography if you've seen professional
photographers have lenses with huge
apertures that's because that gives you
better resolution again same trade-off
at a different different wavelengths but
but here we see the version and and
basically radio frequencies so summarize
non-uniform resolution across the field
a few better at small angles meaning
down bore side worse at larger angles
and also to improve your DOA resolution
you need arrays with bigger apertures
either more elements or space them
further apart bigger aperture better
resolution okay
yes
and a little bit more about what FS
double Prime is yes so fsw Prime here
question is what is this term so this is
essentially uh the the sampling rate of
our signal across the antenna Dimension
so if I go back
um where we were on the DSP slide okay
so if you look at this
um basically data cube right
if if you look at the three axes
across each axis there is a sampling
rate right so horizontally the sampling
rate is your ADC sampling rate that's
your n index and then if you go down the
columns what we call the slow time the
sampling rate is the time between chirps
right so when you have multiple chips in
a frame and then if you go across the
the virtual antennas the sampling rate
is that f f double Prime s which is
dictated by the physical spacing of your
antennas right so it's like kind of like
the spatial sampling rate instead of a
temporal sampling rate another way to
think about it is let me try to
sketch it maybe
on this slide that we wear
so so if you have
if this is these are the elements of
your virtual array
that are a distance D apart okay and
then if you have some incoming
Echo wave at some angle from a Target uh
essentially what these antennas give you
they're going to sample the phase of
this wavefront right at positions that
are D apart right so it's this F double
Prime s
which is equal to 1 over D is the
spatial sampling rate
of your antenna array for the incoming
Echo basically that's how far apart you
sample the phase of that incoming
incoming wave and uh
it it has it matters because we are
trying to estimate that phase so
um for instance if you don't sample it
fine enough you could not find very high
frequencies so you kind of can see
D should matter when it comes to the
field of view of your of your radar if
these two large that means you're
sampling too coarsely so you cannot find
high frequencies in your fft which means
large angles angle of arrivals cannot be
cannot be determined basically
um but back to your question F double
Prime is basically the sampling rate
along the antenna axis it's a spatial
sampling rate not not a temporal it's a
spatial sampling rate uh across the
antennas
okay so that's
um
that's about the the
DOA resolution so again to improve the
resolution you need to increase the
virtual aperture size uh we call that a
which is equal to P times the total
number of antennas times the spacing
which is the total aperture size
basically
uh what about the the maximum detectable
maximum unambiguously detectable DOA and
that's basically the field of view what
is the maximum angle that that you can
detect that exactly like the case of
range and Doppler processing is
determined by the maximum frequency that
your fft gives you right so the fft
again if if the sampling rate is f
double Prime right in the fft
if this is frequency remember that ffts
are periodic with a period of the
sampling rate right and here because our
anger of arrival can be positive or
negative the period that we choose we
choose to go from minus the sampling
rate F double Prime s over 2 2 F double
Prime s over 2. so this is the period
that we look at when it comes to finding
the angle of arrival anything outside
this we ignore because it's just a
repetition of this this this first
period okay so if you restrict your
research to that the maximum angle that
you can find is basically half your
sampling rate okay so your F Theta Max
is just F double Prime s over 2 and then
your angle becomes arc sine of Lambda
times that okay and as I just said what
is f double Prime that's 1 over d That's
one over the spacing between your your
antennas so your Theta Max becomes arc
sine of Lambda over to D okay here's
another again math is math but the
inside here is to improve your field of
view meaning to increase data Max
um your your field of view is
technically two times Theta Max because
you go from both plus and minus so it's
from minus absolute value of theta Max
to plus absolute value of theta Max so
fov is two times that and to increase
that uh main thing that you can change
and this is this D so if you make your D
smaller if you place your antennas more
closely
um that improves your field of view
basically because of this the most
common choice for D is half a wavelength
because if you choose your D to be
Lambda over 2 what happens is that your
Theta Max becomes arc sine
of Lambda
over Lambda which is arc sine of one so
you basically get the full 180 degree
field of view and and that's that's as
good as it gets basically
um so
um most most common Ula 99 of radar
arrays you see out there if you just
open them up and look at the antenna you
would see a Lambda over to uniform
uniform linear array and that's exactly
because of this
um and again this should make sense
exactly as when we talk about time
series signals if you want to be able to
see higher frequencies you need to
sample them more finely in time here if
you want to see larger doas we need to
sample the phase more finely in space so
you need a more tightly packed antenna
array with a smaller D to be able to see
larger frequencies and larger
frequencies in this case mean larger
directions of arrival okay now what
happens if your D is larger than Lambda
over 2 such that your Theta Max is
I'm just going to make up a number as an
example so if your Theta Max
this is a thought experiment we have an
array with some D and the Theta Max
comes out to be 50 degrees
okay so the full field of view is 2
times that 100 degrees fov right fov
100 degrees
and now I take that radar out in the
field
what happens to the targets that are
outside this field of view like if I
have a Target at 130 degrees which is a
very strong reflector like a corner
reflector what would happen do we not
see anything in our process data Cube do
we see something what do you think will
happen
anyone
who is your smaller angle like something
like
that's correct so we will see something
so let's see what will happen so here if
you look at our DOA fft in this case
right we said we are going to look from
minus F double Prime s over 2 to F
double Prime s over 2. now in terms of
angles we said that in this case this
corresponds to 50 degrees
and this is negative 50 degrees
right the Theta that that corresponds to
those frequencies now again ffts are
periodic right so as as the angle the OA
of the target is is
increasing let's say on the positive
side so there's there's going to be like
a peak and it's going to get closer and
closer to that 50 degrees as it crosses
let me use a different color as it
crosses our 50 degree so if I have a
Target that is physically at 70 degrees
remember we are always looking at this
first period so what happens is that
we'll see the Alias Peak from the
previous period that is now showing at a
very small a very large and negative
angle right so you will see something
but it shows up at the wrong DOA for you
and that's that's called wrapping again
there's this periodic signal and and
things don't disappear they just wrap
around right ffts are are periodic so so
that's a big problem right so very
important it's not like if you design
something and you found a a fov of 100
degrees you're fine anything that's
outside 100 degrees just doesn't show up
no they actually will show up and they
will completely mess up your radar image
because because they wrap around and
show at the wrong DOA things don't
disappear they just wrap around very
important and again that's another
reason why the safe choice is to go with
the that is Lambda over two then you
cover the 480 degrees stuff that's
behind you you don't even physically you
know hit them with your with your chips
so everything that's in front of you
then you know that things don't wrap
around and that's that's your safe bet
basically
um
if you want to design a radar that
physically does not see outside say 100
degrees the only option you have is to
design antennas with radiation patterns
that are contained in 100 degrees and
then physically you don't radiate
outside that cone and then you're
guaranteed to not see targets that are
outside that field of view then you can
place them at a Lambda bigger than
Lambda over to spacing make sense
did I clarify your answers the question
about the the F double Prime okay good
um
okay so
let's see
so that's about the DOA resolution and
the maximum field of view that you can
get with this this algorithm
now again I want to uh
um again re-emphasize the fact that
first of all
exactly every DSP step that we developed
for the fmcw radar range estimation
velocity estimation and now finally
angle estimation these all turned out to
be spectral estimation problems
and the fft algorithm again it's the
simplest most efficient thing you can do
but in terms of performance it is not
the best performing algorithm right
that's very very important to note and
that means there is huge opportunity in
the DSP domain to improve the
performance of these types of Radars now
specifically for the dbf the dbf method
we developed the digital beam forming
that is ffts
it's it's even more limited because of
of of uh another fact which is that
algorithm is only compatible with
uniform linear arrays there are more
General algorithms actually in your
homework you will develop a better
algorithm that works for any array not
just Ula and you would see how how that
works it's just an extension of our fft
algorithm basically
um now when it comes to DOA specifically
that a lot of uh you know research
efforts have been spent on better DOA
algorithms on on radar because usually
uh the resolution that you get from ffts
for range and velocity estimation is
considered good enough for most robotic
applications but the resolution you get
from the fft for the DOA is really not
that great and especially we just saw
that it even degrades towards large
angles so it's it's very limited so a
lot of the research efforts have been in
the in the algorithm space have been
focused on super resolution DOA methods
so if you look at the literature there's
tons and tons of interesting algorithms
that people have tried successfully to
improve their resolution DOA resolution
of Radars roughly you can you know
categorize them into three types of
algorithms there's quadratic methods
like cap on there's Subspace techniques
these are very you know linear algebra
based and statistics based methods like
music and a spirit and there is more
modern compressive sensing techniques
like the iterative Adaptive approach or
the orthogonal matching Pursuit OMP very
very You Know Rich interesting active
research area for those of you are
interested in radar DSP and this still
has
has has uh you know a lot of room for
improvement we are not not nearly there
when it comes to you know really modern
interesting radar uh DSP just to give
you an idea of like how much you can
improve
um
let's say that the DOA
here there are two plots the top one
is the DOA that you get from our fft
method right so here we had we're just
looking at at the 1D DOA fft and the
ground truth that we had two Targets at
Theta hat one Theta had two and so your
x-axis is Theta is the DOA and the
y-axis is the magnitude of the fft that
you get in DB and here you see yes like
your two
largest peaks in this fft are actually
at the correct doas of the ground truth
Target but if I just showed you this
without telling you where the targets
are or how many targets were in the
scene I mean you might have said I don't
know maybe this is also a target maybe
this is also a target maybe this is also
a Target or maybe this is also a Target
so you might guess or even like a C4
algorithm might give you like five or
six Peaks instead of just two if it's
not tuned perfectly right now you use a
better algorithm so here is the
iterative Adaptive approach everything
is kept the same same array same
waveform same sampling rate same
everything only the DOA algorithm
changed and now look at the performance
gain that you get I mean looking at the
second one it's absolutely clear that
there's only two Targets and you can
even by just you know comparing the
width of the Peaks you can also tell
that you get much much better resolution
so you get Dynamic better dynamic range
by almost 10 DB better resolution by a
factor of you know five to ten and and
iaea is not even you know that modern an
algorithm I mean if you check the IAA
paper that that I've put in there I mean
this is like I don't know
10 20 years old algorithm it's not even
that new so again just to just to show
you how much room for improvement there
is when it comes to radar DSP
okay very briefly we talked about just
one ddoa uh everything we did we were
assuming like a uniform linear array and
just Azimuth angle 2D DOA uh
exact same so if you have a 2d uniform
linear array like I've I've shown here
and the 2D again it's it's a spanning
now in a plane and then in each axis the
spacings are uniform so they're in say
your antenna elements or virtual antenna
elements in this case are in the YZ
plane and
in the y-axis there d sub y apart and in
the in the exact and the z-axis they're
d sub Z apart okay so that's like a 2d
Ula
then the exact same essentially
algorithm is applicable except you do it
separately for Azimuth and elevation so
you end up doing two ffts for DOA one
gives you Azimuth one gives you
elevation and then everything works and
then you basically can do uh full 3d
localization I'm not going to go through
the math because it's essentially the
same as 1D but it's it's in there and
and you can you can go over it if if
you're interested uh okay so
um
just gonna
skip here and next topic is
um this idea of waveform orthogonality
for for mimo radar so when we developed
this
um
concept of virtual array
uh there was a implicit assumption in
there which is extremely important but
we kind of didn't talk about it till now
which was the fact that in our DOA
processing we assumed that uh the
signals transmitted by different
transmitter antennas are completely
separable and by by separable I mean uh
basically the if signals which we called
Sif of KQ which correspond to
transmitter number K and receiver number
Q all of those we assume that they're
individually without interference
accessible to our DSP pipeline okay and
we just basically called every KQ
combination a virtual antenna and then
we work with the virtual array right
so so that's a very important assumption
because for instance if all the
transmitters are transmitting at the
same time at the same frequency
the same waveform there's no way the
receivers can separate out which
waveform that they received was coming
from Which transmitter right so for this
separability assumption to hold which is
the underlying Assumption of basically
all of our mimo DSP
essentially we need to have
orthogonality between the signals that
different transmitters transmit okay and
again by orthogonality I mean perfectly
separable there's no overlap or
interference between between different
different transmitters
um when it comes to orthogonality
there's different ways you can add that
to the signals so there's essentially
three main techniques to orthogonalize
the way the the the the transmitter is
in a mimo system uh first one is time
division multiplexing or TDM which is
the simplest thing it can do basically
uh you don't you don't run all your
transmits at the same time you sequence
them so transmit number one sends
everything if all other transmitters are
silent and number two senses chirped and
number three sends a chip and so on and
then you you repeat okay so that's the
the concept of TDM you can also do
frequency Division multiplexing if you
the signals that are sent by different
transmitters this Center frequency is
different enough that they don't overlap
in frequency so the TDM makes sure they
don't overlap in time fdm or frequency
division multiplexing makes make sure
they're separable in frequency and the
third one which is code division
Multiplex saying basically uses a
special waveforms such that the
waveforms themselves are orthogonal and
separable one example we have seen is
for instance M sequences we know that
the cross correlations of different M
sequences is almost zero so they are
separable exactly as GPS does right GPS
receivers can separate out signals that
they receive from different different
satellites so to ensure again
separability we need to orthogonalize
the signals you either do it in time in
frequency or in code those are the three
basically standard techniques most
common one that is that is done today
for fmcw mimo is is TDM and that's the
one I'll I'll talk a little more about
fdm and CDM are not used much today I
hope we'll see more of them mostly
because they add complexity to the
hardware but TDM is is just you know
Hardware is the same it just makes your
your DSP a little more more involved so
that's the main reason but in terms of
performance fdm and TDM can achieve
better performance than DanTDM so what
is the TDM uh mimo principle so the TDM
model principle again very simple we can
just look at this picture here to fully
understand it so one frame of the TDM
mimo waveform essentially is is broken
into remember for the case of a sizo
system we had M chirps in a frame now we
have M what we call Chip loops from 0 to
M minus 1. and what happens inside every
chip Loop is exactly as I said your all
the transmitters sequentially transmit
so first your tx1 sends the chip every
other TX is silent then your tx2 sends a
trip then your tx3 sends a chip then
you're all the way to the txn and then
you go to the next trip Loop and repeat
so the overall waveform that you get in
tdmi mode is like this so I'm I'm using
different colors for different
transmitters and as you see they are
completely separable in time so every
receiver antenna when they receive an
echo they know exactly Which transmitter
it corresponds to because only one
transmitter was active at that time so
TDM basically it's it's kind of trivial
to to separate out the signals and then
construct your virtual array however
as everything else there is no free
launch so there it comes with a couple
of trade-offs first one is of course it
makes your frame time longer right
because now we are time multiplexing
between different tx's so to send the
same number of chips so to keep this m
constant same number of chips per
um
transmit antenna if you do TDM now your
frame takes a factor of ntx longer so if
you have 10 TXS and TDM my modem then
your frame time becomes 10 times longer
which means your frame rate is dropping
by a factor of 10 right so that's the
first trade-off everything becomes a
slower because you're sharing time okay
but it has even even more important
consequences and uh
the the main one that basically becomes
a big limitation of of TDM mimo is if
you look at this picture here
uh remember so when we're looking at the
the data cube of our of our radar we
have different sampling rates right so
you have your ADC sampling rate that's
your uh fast time access right those are
like the rows of the raw data Cube and
then you have your slow time
which if you remember the sampling rate
is the time between two consecutive
chirps that are transmitted from the
same transmitter so if you look at your
green transmitter one sample here and
one sample here
now that is our new Slow Time
sampling interval so if we do TDM mimo
our slow time is going to become a
factor of ntx is slower right so the
sampling rate in the Doppler axis is
going to drop by a factor of ntx what
does that mean if you remember the
Doppler resolution and maximum velocity
equations that we developed the maximum
Doppler frequency that you can detect
because it's tied to the fft is
proportional to the basically the
inverse of your slow time which is the
sampling rate across the Doppler axis
sampling rate drops which means maximum
frequency drops so the maximum velocity
that you can draw detect drops by a
factor of ntx in in TDM mimo case
this can be depending on your
application you might not care about it
if if that maximum velocity is still
acceptable you're like okay fine I I'll
just I'll just live with it but in
certain applications this might be a
block here already so
um say in autonomous driving originally
it designed your uh frame and Chip
waveform parameters such that the
maximum detectable velocity was 100
miles per hour and now you TDM mymo it
with 10 transmitters your sampling rate
across Doppler drops by a factor of 10
which means your maximum Doppler
velocity drops to a factor of 10. now
from 100 miles per hour you're down to
10 miles per hour that's absolutely not
acceptable for autonomous driving I mean
everything pretty much and on the roads
is is moving faster than 10 miles per
hour so that that can become a big a big
issue so again here's a math your
maximum detectable velocity uh
originally if you remember it was Lambda
over 4 times T where T was the chirp
duration
that was for the case of a siso system
now for a TDM mimo system it becomes
Lambda over 4 times T Loop where T Loop
is the loop time which is n number of T
X's times the chip time so your maximum
velocity again is dropping by a factor
of ntx compared to the size or case can
be a huge problem what can you do about
it uh turns out there's a number of
techniques this is again one of those
very active research areas for for radar
but there's a number of techniques that
that you can use to essentially increase
back the maximum velocity you can detect
very briefly what you can do you can
either design special antenna arrays
that help you recover a larger you know
or unwrap your your velocity fft and
recover larger velocities you can design
special waveforms that again enable you
to recover large velocities in the case
of TDM mimo or you can basically design
a better DSP algorithm so instead of
just doing an ffd you do something more
sophisticated which doesn't have the
limitations associated with fft and a
big limitation associated with fft is
again the maximum velocity you can
detect is tied to the sampling rate but
there are other algorithms which don't
operate that way and then they can
recover large velocities in the case of
tdmi so again TDM mimo very easy
technique to
basically give you separability or
orthogonality between the the
transmitted waveforms in the case of
mimo but this is the first limitation of
it it has a second I wouldn't call it
limitation but a caveat that it actually
is not highlighted enough in literature
and oftentimes people miss it and the
system still works with significantly
degraded performance so I just want to
highlight that here
that is called phase from motion
so what this second thing is is
very briefly if we look at one of these
chirp Loops that you do in a TDM mimo
configuration again remember that your
transmitters are going sequentially your
tx1 fires and tx2 files and tx3 files
all the way to txn okay and if if we
look at our original signal model that
that we had on the board here we said
that the if signal you get from virtual
element number P it has two components
it has this temporal component Sif of T
and it has this spatial phase which is e
to the J Omega i p right and we we
basically work with this e to the J
Omega to to recover direction of arrival
now for TDM my mode there is a third
term in the
phase term and the signal model which we
call the TDM phase and that is and added
because of the fact that your chips are
not sent at the same time from different
transmitters so each transmit
index k
because it starts at a different point
in time the phase that you receive from
that uh is is going to be different from
from different transmitters and that is
this third term which is e to the minus
J 2 pi FD is the Doppler frequency K is
the index of the transmitter
antenna not the virtual antenna but the
physical transmitter antenna so it goes
from 1 to ntx times Big T which is the
which is the trip duration so that's
that's basically T so more concretely at
the start of every chip Loop you can
assume that term is is is is there's no
face for your first transmitter but your
second transmitter because it starts T
seconds later there's this additional
phase e to the minus J2 Pi f d t your
third transmitter has a phase e to the
minus J 2 pi ft times 2T and so on if
you don't if I clean this up if you
don't model this term and compensate for
it it's just gonna effectively
[Music]
corrupt your Omega KQ phase and
that means it's going to degrade your
DOA right estimation but it's extremely
easy to compensate for this right
because after we do our range and
Doppler processing essentially we know
this this TDM phase term because we have
found FD for every you know processed
cell in the data Cube and K is just a
transmitter index which is known and for
every slice of the of the data Cube and
Big T is again the tube duration so this
entire TDM phase term is known and all
you need to do to compensate for it is
after you do your range and Doppler ffts
you do this additional step which we're
multiplying by e to the J minus that TDM
phase to cancel it out and pure cell you
multiply by this term it cancels out the
TDM phase and then you do your
doasft very simple step it's just one
complex multiplication extremely
important if you miss this you're going
to significantly degrade the DOA
performance here's one example this is
very simple scene just you know one
Target in in the scene and this is kind
of the point Cloud if you will to the
point Cloud also we can think of it as a
range Azimuth map of of the target so
that's that's basically the target
um that's what you get if you do proper
TDM phase compensation if you forget
that step multiplying by the inverse of
the of the TDM phase
it still kind of sort of works you do
get a point Cloud but look how much blur
this is compared to it's blurred it's
also not exactly at the right DOA so if
you if you if you compare this angle
Theta
was was this angle Theta you would see
they're not the same there's a little
bit of rotation because again you have
you've affected the face extremely again
important do not forget this if you're
working with a TDM mimo system and I've
seen textbooks that entirely miss this
they don't even mention that that that
this is a critical step and nobody knows
because it kind of sort of works it's
just not as good as it could it could
possibly be
questions
okay so again this was one way of
ensuring separability of the transmitted
signals using the time division
multiplexing concept there's frequency
Division and and code division
multiplexing that
um I'm not gonna uh
I'm not going to go over them because
most standard Hardwares don't support
them anyway but I hope you see more of
them the math and the the the the
explanations are in the notes if if
you're interested okay so uh we're gonna
basically close the radar chapter just
with a few a few remarks
um radar again it's extremely useful and
uh there's there's a lot you can do with
it and the state of the radar today it
still has across the board from Hardware
design antenna design algorithms
waveform design and by algorithm I mean
ranging Doppler Target detection
direction of arrival across the world
like any any point that you you put your
finger on it still has a ton of room for
improvement so I I really believe like
in the next you know 10 15 20 years
you're gonna see a significant
Improvement and and what Radars can do
and as part of that there's a number of
challenges that that I want to highlight
that need to be basically figured out
and they're actively being researched on
one is the multi-path effect
so multi-path effect essentially what it
is is that
if you have big flat surfaces in the
scene uh your millimeter wave emissions
can basically bounce off of them kind of
like they can act like mirrors almost
okay so here if you have like a radar on
this blue car ego vehicle and and and
the red is like the Target in front of
it of course you would have this Direct
Travel path
of the millimeter wave and that gives
you the real Target but if it's driving
on a road and you have like metal guard
guard guardrails on the side it can
happen that you actually
hit the the guard rail and you get
reflected Hit the Target and then you
take the same path back
right and if you do do your standard DSP
on this of course the receiver DSP
doesn't know that this this this Echo
that it received was from a multi-path
so it just processes it and it finds
range and DOA and it would in your point
Cloud it would show as a Target that
that was there which is a ghost Target
it's it's at the wrong DOA and at the
wrong range and it's not even a physical
physical Target so that can be a big
problem again depends on your
application like the environment that
that that you're operating at if there's
you know especially like indoors it's
it's horrible like in this room if we
were to operate radar the ceiling the
floor all the walls would would create a
lot of multi-pass Echoes so we would see
a ton of ghost targets for instance
and again there's different ways it's a
very active research area how you how
you essentially
um
detect and eliminate multi-pass people
have gotten very promising results and
you can do you know special again
antenna design waveform design or or DSP
the other effect is mutual interference
so if you have two Radars on on two
robots or two cars so let's say the red
car here has its own radar and the blue
has its own radar and they're pointing
at each other and the two Radars are
operating at the same frequency at the
same time and sending the same kind of
waveforms then they can interfere
essentially like blind each other right
and uh and and or are or even if not
fully blinding it can significantly
raise the noise floor for instance
because of a lot of inbound interference
so that can be a big problem this is one
of the areas where pmcw Radar really
shines because again as we know these
ranging codes that are used in pmcw the
M sequences all you need to do is use
two different M sequences and then
they're orthogonal and they wouldn't
interfere
fmcw really that's the is not is not
um that good in this area I mean fmcw is
kind of like analog waveforms that
you're sending so they can really
interfere with each other a lot uh and
and again it's it's a very active
research area people have come up with
very clever you know algorithms to
essentially mitigate this this Mutual
interference
and the third one is um
a physical Effect called spillover and a
spillover is basically direct coupling
from a transmitter antenna to a receiver
antenna without echoing from a Target
right so if your antennas have very wide
radiation patterns and if transmitter
and receiver antennas are placed closely
which can happen on these uh microstrip
antennas signal can directly spill
basically from the transmitter to the
receiver and then two things happen one
is it because it's very strong right
it's it's right you know next to the
transmitter so you get a very strong
coupling and you eat into the dynamic
range of your receiver but also if you
if you process it it might even show up
as a Target at a very close range right
that that could also also happen
sometimes some receivers apply what is
called range gating so they just ignore
anything that is too close and they say
this is probably spillover if it's like
I don't know less than a couple of
inches they don't even show it it or or
process it but still it can eat into the
dynamic range and best thing you can do
is if you're involved in the antenna
design process is to in simulations
check for how much coupling you get
between transmitter and receiver
antennas and ensure by design by adding
sufficient isolation and spacing between
the antennas ensure that this this
doesn't become a big problem
okay
yes
like adding isolation other than like
putting them further apart
um so depends on what kind the question
is what is an example of adding
isolation aside from just adding space
depends on the type of antenna that
you're working with but again if it's
microstrip antennas like these little
patch antennas on a PCB
if possible one thing you can do is add
ground in between
so let's say ah I ran out of space let
me let me sketch it again so if this is
a
transmit antenna
again microstrip on a PCB if you had a
bit of a just like ground copper
between that and a receiver antenna
that can add isolation but again there's
no free launch because uh if you add
this ground it will also affect the
radiation pattern or the gain pattern of
the antenna uh everything is a trade-off
right so yes you can add ground if you
add it too close you reduce your uh
coupling a lot but you also affect the
radiation pattern a lot and then that
can add extra complications but it's a
technique it is used when you can you
add grounding to to you know basically
help shape it the best thing is just a
space like as much as possible don't
don't place them too close to each other
yeah
if you remember or maybe later you can
check on your your slides there was this
TI PCB that we looked at if you look at
that all the transmit antennas are at
the bottom and all the receiver at the
top with very big spacing between the
two and that's four for isolation
reasons basically so that you don't get
much spillover okay
so that's uh that's pretty much it about
uh about the radar
um again uh I think
radar is probably uh the main sensor for
autonomy which uh still has a ton of
room for improvement across the board
and by across the board I mean
everything from algorithms waveform
design antenna design General Hardware
even like the frequencies that The
Radars are operating at as I told you
now people are researching like 120
gigahertz I've seen researchers on three
four hundred gigahertz you know it's
it's just going to keep improving and I
just want to close this chapter by uh
showing you a very brief
part of a keynote video this was
delivered by the CEO of the a company
called mobileye mobileye is one of the
biggest companies developing sensing
Technologies for autonomy so they they
develop all kinds of different sensors
vision systems Radars lidars very very
interesting company and this is a a part
of the speech that their CEO gave at the
Consumer Electronics Show
last year so this is from January
um
January 2022 relatively recently and
before I I play it basically
um the the point he's making is
um the same thing I just said that that
that radar we're just we just have so
far barely scratched the surface of what
radar can do for autonomy and and that's
the point of of what what he's going to
say next so I'm just gonna
so to give you an idea of the quality of
data that is there because leading radar
output is difficult it's not just it's
not like reading image output or reading
a ladder output
so we trained two two Networks
this is not actionable this is just to
to show what what this radar can do we
train the network that was trained on
radar input landar output
so we put a radar and the ladder
together and then we used the Lander as
output for a neural network to map the
radar to a to ladder
so uh what you see here
is
on the left hand side
the scene seen from a true ladder on the
right hand side the mapping from our
radar this neural network Maps the radar
output to a leader representation as you
can see that there are almost equivalent
let's look a bit more let's let's start
looking at the left hand side so on the
left hand side I'll run this
left is true ladar right is the mapped
radar to to ladder representation it
looks almost identical
so what the point I want to make here is
not the beauty of this neural network
that we designed there's nothing special
about that neural network the point I
want to make here is
quality of the radar data if you can
take that radar data and generate your
presentation that's almost equivalent to
a ladder representation it means that
there is gold to extract from this
leather let me show you on the right
hand side
okay I'll stop here you can you can
watch the full video online but again
the the point is
um
basically uh as as as he said there's
gold to be extracted from from raw radar
signals and the way to extract it by the
way I don't I don't think is what they
did and they even mentioned what they
did is not actionable it was just to
demonstrate by training a neural net
that yes there is gold in there but to
really extract it requires you know
um really deep knowledge starting from
the first physics principles and and
really you know across the board as I
said from antenna design to every step
of the DSP really get deep and see
what's the best that that you can do and
I'm I'm 100 sure like soon uh we're
gonna start seeing Radars with outputs
of of this quality which you can barely
tell from a from a lighter okay and
that's a nice segue into the next
chapter which is going to be about lidar
but before that any questions
about radar
okay good so um lidar again we're gonna
uh do it the same way we did every other
chapter start with a little bit of
History then we talk about the physics
of it from the physics we build up a
system architecture we look at the
system architecture and then finally we
look at uh we developed a signal model
and and we look at the signal processing
algorithms for lidar so lidar stands for
light detection and ranging or also some
people call it laser Imaging detection
and ranging but it's basically a sensor
that uses laser beams for mapping okay
so radar used
radio frequency electromagnetic waves
lidar uses Optical frequency
electromagnetic waves for for mapping
and just just like radar it can
determine the distance or range and the
angle or direction of arrival to targets
and some some lighters as we'll see can
also detect radial velocities of of
objects like like for instance fmcw
radar can do
now where did it all begin
the idea has been around for a very long
time even before lasers were discovered
or invented uh like in the 1930s uh I
think Edward cinch first proposed this
idea of using a Searchlight so basically
columnate a very powerful
light and make a beam that you can shine
to the sky and then based on uh the the
the the light that hits say like uh
aerosols in the atmosphere part of the
light scatters back and then by just
pointing a camera at the scattered light
for instance you can determine the the
density of the atmospheric particles
from the intensity of the scattered
light so that was you know a very high
level concept of of the Searchlight that
was proposed in the in the 30s and then
about the same time
proposed uh the idea of instead of just
shining a beam of light what about
sending short pulses of light and again
this is pretty laser days but if you
send short pulses and look at the
reflected Echoes of those pulses and
here by Echo this is Optical echo of
course
um
uh you can measure the time of flight so
he basically uh proposed the idea of
time of flight measurement uh using
Optics
a few years later in 1936 some very
successful experiments were done again
this was done with visible light but
people could measure ranges up to 3.5
kilometers but very decent accuracy two
to three meters using this idea of short
send a short pulse of light and then
collect back the Echo and and measure
basically range from time to flight
fast forward
years in 1960 the first laser was was
invented and then soon after that people
kind of like put the two ideas together
so lasers what they're really good for
is making very short pulses and you can
also collimate them as we'll see very
easily so you can make very narrow beams
with lasers and also you can send very
short pulses so people started almost
immediately after the laser was invented
first applications people were thinking
of laser rangefinders so Rangefinder is
like a very very simple lidar where it
doesn't give you a full map it just
measures the range to one point right
from this time of flight measurement
and a few years later I mean in early
from the early 60s uh even like
commercial laser rangefinders uh started
hitting the market the first one was
from the huge Aircraft Company very soon
after that actually Stanford got into
the game the Stanford Research Institute
here in Palo Alto uh they they started
doing the first lidar experiments again
these were not
2023 lidar that gives you like a nice 3D
Point Cloud these were just laser
rangefinders but people were essentially
the core concept and the physics is the
same uh and then
um
Swedish army got into the game uh the
the the Soviet Union started basically
building uh rangefinders and you know
especially for military applications uh
and and also for meteorology it it it
started uh uh basically becoming a
commercialized
and then
later in the 70s and the 80s were more
applications of of these uh still range
finders but you can't think of as as you
know early uh early lidars more
applications started becoming uh
um basically common uh wind measurement
missile guidance in the in the military
uh
mapping of the polar ice caps for
instance and police speed guns uh we're
using basically
um
pulses of short Parcels of laser and the
early lidar Concepts
um but it was only uh
at the 1990s where the modern day
Imaging lidars which you know give you
these very nice high resolution 3D Point
clouds that started to to become
commercial
so in comparison Imaging lidars are a
much modern uh although again that core
idea wasn't that was was thought of in
the 30s
it wasn't until the 90s that the
technology maturity was at the level
that you know these modern day uh
Imaging lidars could could be developed
and in that sense it's a much younger
technology compared to say radar or
sonar or other things we have talked
about
um so here are some pictures uh these
are from the the 1930s the early range
finder lidars um so
um this is the SRI mark one lidar sris
again Stanford Research Institute so
this might be somewhere in Palo Alto
actually this this picture
um and uh again there's I mean there's
huge systems and there is there's like a
transmitter and a receiver so one sends
the policy everyone receive the pulse
and then there's there's a lot of you
know equipment to control the the laser
and also process the received Echo to to
measure range so this would just give
you like one range measurement
this is Sri Mark II and this is the one
that the the Howard Hughes uh Aircraft
company made it kind of looks like a
like a rifle interestingly and it's
called the Hughes Collide or Mark II uh
was the marketing term that they were
using and it was like a portable
basically Rangefinder thing
um
here I have a modern Rangefinder you
might have have seen these let's
actually power it on and take a look at
together again it does the exact same
thing so this is not a lidar it's just a
just a rangefinder if I can turn it on
okay so this one it comes with the with
a red laser pointer so this is the red
is just the red laser they don't use it
for ranging it's just for aiming so I
know where I'm where I'm pointing at and
then if I hit it then it gives me the
distance 8.65 meters okay so again this
is not a lidar but you see like because
if you can do this you can also make a
lighter if you do this fast enough and
you like scan your beam and you do like
one range measurement per position and
then at for each range measurement I
also know where I'm pointing at so the
DOA is kind of trivial for lidar because
the beam is so focused I just need to
know where I'm physically pointing it to
I don't need to do complex DSP e and you
just like scan it and do a bunch of
range measurements and then you you
build a basically a 3D map and that's
how essentially lidar Works
um so you can kind of
see from here that the DSP is going to
be much much more simple than than radar
for instance because part of the
complication of the dsp4 radar is the
fact that especially for mimo radar with
microstrip antennas you have very wide
beam patterns so you receive Echoes from
everything in the in the scene at a very
wide field of view and then you have to
like untangle everything and figure out
the range of every Target the DOA of
every Target and the velocity of every
Target in DSP versus in lidar you pretty
much can assume the signal that you
receive at any point in time it's coming
from just one Target because your beam
is so focused it's just millimeters you
know wide and and it's very very
localized so this is the 30s now fast
forward to
2020s now of course we have much much
better better lidars you can you can get
you know very high resolution 3D maps
from them like this one from
Stanford campus and and they're using
many different applications oceanography
meteorology even like some cell phones
these days have built-in little lidars
that are used for arvr applications and
of course in autonomy especially in in
self-driving or autonomous vehicles uh
lidars are one of the key key enabling
uh basically sensors
okay so lighter physics uh very briefly
again uh as I just showed you with the
rangefinder the principle of operation
is extremely simple you have a Laser
Source okay so it generates a a laser
for you it goes through TX Optics and
bioptix I mean just just lenses right
what the lenses do as as we'll see it
will basically make this nice collimated
narrow beam of laser for you that
doesn't diverge too too quickly so then
you get this this pencil beam that goes
and hits a Target and then you get this
part of the light echoed back or
reflected back and then on the receive
side you also have some Optics or lenses
and then the Optics basically focuses
the received light Echo into a photo
detector
and from the photo detector we have we
get some signal waveform out that we can
we can pass to our DSP
and then basically estimate range and
and and possibly possibly velocity
um so again exact same principle of
operation as as radar and and and sonar
but you know operating at different
wavelengths and and because of that it
comes with very different performance
metrics uh you also want to basically
scan your your transmitter beam as I
said you want to you know keep keep
aiming it at different locations and you
want to do this very fast I mean a lot
of us today good ones can give you
multiple million measurements per second
like two to five million points per
second basically is is what modern day
lidars operate at and uh and and so
basically we're gonna study this
starting from the physics we'll look at
Laser physics first then we talk about
these beams which are called gaussian
beams and how they're generated how they
behave we talk about the Optics which
basically culminate made the beam for
you and then we talk about the
principles of photo detection what is a
photo detector how does it work what is
the physics of it and then once we do
that we basically can complete our
system architecture and then we build a
signal model for St and finally we talk
about DSP exact same you know story as
as we did for radar and sonar I think
this is a good place to stop and then we
will continue next time